after 21 days of tension debate and at
time despair all eyes are on the
nation's capitol this hour as police
signal they're preparing to end the
demonstration and blockade by the
so-called freedom convoy shawn o'shea
now with the latest i'm sean o'shea in
ottawa so thursday morning arrived and
so did police officers but this blockade
in front of parliament still has not
been cleared and they've not made a
concerted effort in order to try to
clear it out police were on the street
here this morning in addition to ottawa
police there were members of the ontario
provincial police we saw london police
and other officers here handing out
notes handing out flyers to truckers who
remain parked here at one point
protesters swarmed around some police
officers who were handing out those
notes to some of the truckers
and so the police keep walking around
they've not taken any concerted action
here it's mostly just at this point
handing out those notes walking about
here making their presence known most at
least most of the streets in this area
of ottawa near parliament here remain
blocked off it's early in the day and
these protesters these truckers say
they're going to dig in and they again
claim that they're not planning to leave
notwithstanding the order that they must
so the police have just started to hand
out more notices they're informing the
people who have been protesting here
that they have to leave
and things have gotten a little bit
tense now because they've been chased
out
many of them have been chased out
[Music]
standoff of some sort here this all
started shortly after eight o'clock this
morning
police from
london and from the opp
ottawa police
we've seen all of them here right now
as i said the goal is to try to get
notices to these people which inform
them that they must leave
or else but as they gave those notices
out just right in front of parliament
hill just right in front of the
parliament building uh there was a
flurry of activity uh many other
supporters came over started to shout
started to get angry
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]